[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
howard beck sports illustrated senior
writer
co-host of the crossover podcast joining
us
on the program howard let me start with
that give me the logic behind the nets
picking up blake griffin
good morning dan um listen i i think
let me address what's not the logic
behind it this is not the nets
loading up on yet another all-star to
join
kyrie and james harden and kd and
deandre jordan
people are talking about well five years
ago could you imagine these guys all
together
yeah yeah five years ago these guys
weren't the same guys well three of them
were
um de'andre jordan's not that guy
anymore and blake griffin's not the guy
that he was when he was playing with
deandre jordan from lob city
in la he
we have a very small sample size dan of
what blake griffin did in detroit this
season
and i i'm wavering between
looking at that sample size and saying
wow i think blake griffin might be done
versus blake griffin is on a young
rebuilding team
in which he is no longer a focal point
at all
and they've got nothing to play for and
maybe there's a second
wind for blake griffin with a team that
matters and he's
joining one now but i will tell you dan
about a month ago
when all the chatter first started about
they're going to try to trade blake
griffin which was never realistic
they're going to cut him loose
whatever's going to happen i checked him
with some scouts and they basically said
look it's painful to watch him
i can't watch him it's it's he's that
far from what he was what can he still
do
he's a really good passer for a big he
can hit the mid-range shot he's a good
mid-range shooter
when he's got his lift when his legs are
there i just don't know what's
left after all the injuries he's been
through and yeah 31 is young
for this even in this league but as you
know blake griffin's just been through
so much in terms of surgeries
and injuries and i don't know what's
left i honestly don't but the nets
were really thin in the front court and
now they're a little less than
watching the game last night everybody
loves the three
and i i went back and i i
asked statsy could i get a a summary of
the game of how many lay-ups and dunks
and how many threes
how many mid-range jumpers were there
last night
there was one mid-range jumper
last night can you see a scenario though
howard where
somebody is going to be
counter-intuitive to the three
and all of a sudden just go we want you
to deal with
our strength which might be low post
you know that you actually use a big man
as a big man
or are we you know we're i don't want to
say
stuck with the three but you know that
the three is going to be around
a long long time yeah i mean the
emphasis on the three dan is not going
away
the uh continued shift toward
uh the three ball over mid-range is not
going away
i don't know where we top out um kirk
goldsberry of espn's
has a phenomenal book on this called
sprawl ball where he talks about the
logical extremes and whether this
eventually has to lead to
any number of potential solutions right
moving the three-point line even further
back i mean people like adding the
four-point line whatever
that do i'm not sure if that solves the
problem
um but what if we removed it
if we removed it entirely you would have
a jammed up court any uh
boring game and you wouldn't have people
slashing to the hoop anymore and nobody
would watch
okay um i i do we're not going back
and the thing is there are skilled
two-point mid-range guys in this league
kawhi leonard devin booker zach levine
kevin durant pretty much actually all of
the elite scorers
most of them are really good in the
mid-range maybe not james harden
um but a lot of these guys are really
good there but the fact is
if you're great in the mid-range but the
other team is is just
a little bit less good from three-point
range as you know
you're gonna keep losing ground so as
long as somebody's shooting a lot of
threes if the other team is taking 43s
and you're taking 10 out of some
principled stand in favor of the
mid-range
uh you're gonna lose because math why do
you think steph curry
entered the three-point shooting contest
um
because why not listen the the my
colleague michael penitz at si
i thought like a month ago had the best
idea about the all-star game which was
just send the all-stars and then have
the all-stars do all of the events
in which case maybe we would have
finally gotten lebron the dunk contest
probably not but maybe zion maybe um i
think this was
this is uh efficiency this was let's try
to invite as
few extra bodies as possible and steph
is an obvious candidate and steph says
i'm there anyway we're doing it all the
same day sure why not i mean that's my
guess
howard we got to get rid of the skills
competition because it feels like it's a
white guy event
you know hey who can throw a a european
white
guy and you got a crisp pass that you're
going to throw into a net you're going
to dribble around some cones and then
somebody maybe will bank in a three
um i used to do those drills at summer
camp
it was not called a skills competition
howard it is not good
uh i i wrote this because they asked us
to predict
all the events um which is a kind of a
goofy exercise in and of itself
and my line on the skills competition
was fun fact i have never watched this
and dan i i'm happy to tell you i did
not
break my streak last night i still did
not well i turned it on just in time to
see sabonis accepting the trophy i went
oh
darn i missed it again yeah i watched i
watched
and then i kept going this this isn't
really
a great skills company i i think we
think well there's a seven
footer out there well we're well past a
seven footer who can
handle the ball pass the ball and shoot
the ball
that's the whole league yes yeah that's
the whole league
now the the fact is the only event that
you can count on year in and year out
to be uh interesting watchable fun is
the three-point shootout it is
like that one is bulletproof dan yeah
the game itself the all-star game
most years and uh the dunk contest
last night was terrible and it's every
once every four or five years we get one
that's so electric
that we go okay it's back we don't have
to kill it and then a year like this we
go
maybe we're out of ideas for the dunk
contest and yeah the skills
competition's just useless
and if lebron had been in the dunk
contest then i
i know the critics would say oh i
thought you were going to conserve your
energy why aren't you conserving your
energy
why don't you let the young guys have
the stage lebron couldn't win
if he slipped into the dunk contest it
would have been awesome but the critics
would have come out and said
should you be doing that shouldn't you
conserve your energy let somebody else
have the spotlight lebron
yeah maybe um i think at this point
people would have just been thrilled
just to see him finally do it but i also
you're not going to do it
in year 18 at 36. like the window for
lebron to have done that
closed quite a while ago and i think
that's the part of the problem is that
the stars of today only see downside
this it's well i'm i you enter the
league on day one as a superstar with
all these expectations and all this hype
and everything what happens if you
get beaten by you know anthony simons
you know cash of stanley like you don't
want to put yourself in that position
and so i think that's why we don't see
the superstars do it anymore as we did
back in the day with jordan or years
later with kobe
he's howard beck he uh covers the league
sports illustrated senior writer
uh handicapped the second half of the
season let's assume anthony davis is
healthy
are the lakers when healthy
better than the nets when healthy ooh
that's a spicy question and a relevant
one i mean listen
we've got at least a dozen a dozen ten
maybe i don't know different possible
combinations because
i think there are four or five teams
that could come out of each conference
certainly in the west maybe three in the
east um
if it's nets versus lakers i'm still
leaning lakers
because we know they can defend and
because i don't know
what the nets are doing with anthony
davis now listen
to our earlier discussion if anthony
davis is crushing it at the rim
but james harden and kyrie irving and
kevin durant are reigning threes
uh math might favor the nets anyway but
can the nets deal with anthony davis
no uh now kevin durant has some
experience playing against lebron in the
finals
and those two will check each other well
but you know that because that's the
first question i have dan every time we
it's the hypothetical what about the
jazz versus the lakers can the jazz make
the final
what are they doing with lebron and
anthony davis like that's the first
question for every opponent
the nets are so potent offensively and
if they just
ratchet up the defense to a respectable
level and can place them in the fourth
quarter
because if the if the nets are within 10
points of you in the fourth quarter
you may already be in trouble because
all they have to do is decide to play
defense for about five minutes
and just you know rain threes on you
they
they're unguardable they're absolutely
unguardable and they have just enough
role players
who can benefit and hit open threes that
trying to guard
durant hard and irving at the same time
is is an impossibility
i was looking at the numbers going into
the all-star break
points per game league one
112 points per game is what it's being
averaged
that's the highest since 1969 when it
was 115 points a game
i i tune in and i can watch a game not
going into
overtime and somebody's got 140 points
howard and
like i go i remember when when the
knicks and the cat remember when
fratello and pat riley nearly ruined the
game
when they were getting those hey first
team to 90
when riley was with the knicks and
fratello with the cavs i went oh my god
look at this you can get that almost at
halftime it feels like in these
nba games is it too much of a good thing
well i'll say this no one's nostalgic
for mike fratello and pat riley ruining
the game and slowing things down and
having like you know
70 to 67 final scores um
i i mean some people are nostalgic for
that nba i don't know why they are
is are we too far is the pendulum swim
too far in the other direction i think
the league
asks itself that question all the time
like there's some really smart people at
olympic tower who
are constantly wondering about this and
and thinking about it
and in the earlier discussion we had
about how how far does this three-point
binge
go does it hit a logical extreme where
it warps the game
too much and we have to try to
recalibrate and how do you do that
i think they're thinking about that all
the time i don't think we're at a crisis
point yet
uh with the nba i think the the ratings
have bounced back really well this year
and you know last year was
you know obviously a weird year with the
pandemic the bubble basketball in the
summer all this stuff
and so as long as people are watching as
long as the game
is fun i think we're okay they're always
going to be some basketball purists who
feel like
scores are too high there's not enough
mid-range there's not enough of
you know diversity within the offense
all right fine but
if people are watching uh you know and
and
the the revenue's still pouring in i i
think they're just going to continue on
this course
howard great to talk to you we
appreciate your time we'll check in with
you during the second half of the season
thank you
always pleasure dan thank you that's
howard beck sports illustrated senior
writer co-host of the crossover podcast
siriusxm
nba radio analyst